[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
My name is Manfred.
I'm here today with Rajeev.
And we're going to talk about
building cloud-powered Android
applications.
So this is going to be
very much a hands-on demo.
We're actually going
to take an application,
write it back and forth
now, live, in 15 minutes.
And we're also going to give
you a bit of introduction
before we do that.
And then we're going
to talk about some
of the future directions.
And we'll try to
leave a minute or two
for questions and answers.
So let's start with an overview.
For this demo, we're going to be
using Android Studio and Google
Cloud Endpoints.
And let me just give a quick
overview of each of these.
So Android Studio is
an open source ID.
It's built for Android.
And it's based on
an IntelliJ IDEA.
Now, what that means is that
it has a lot of good coding
assistance tools to help
you write quality Java code.
So things like context aware,
code completion, and the chain
method autocompletion,
optimizing the imports,
built-in spell checker, all
of that kind of nice stuff.
It also has a nice integrated
visual and layout designer,
which means that you
can drag and drop
visual elements into your app.
And it also comes with a whole
bunch of static code analysis
tools.
We call them linters.
I think that's how they're
known in the industry as well.
And they help you to
build quality apps.
So can check things
like simple security
issues and compatibility issues,
all of that kind of things.
And finally, Android
Studio is very
well-integrated
with Gradle build.
Which means that you can use
the same build files and build
setup for ID, command line,
your continuous integration
server, all of these things.
So that's one half.
Now, the other half is
Google Cloud Endpoints.
And what Google Cloud
Endpoints points do
is they provide
a very simple way
to build server-side
logic for your apps
on Google App Engine Platform.
And since it's
running on App Engine,
it's benefiting from
all of these things
that we just spoke about
throughout the day-- so
auto scaling, high availability,
all of those nicenesses.
So this is how a basic
architecture looks like.
You have a backend running
on App Engine instances.
And then you have Google
Cloud Endpoints clients.
And one thing that Endpoints
does for you is they
take the plumbing out
of API programming
by, for example, marshaling
Java objects into JSON objects,
providing rest APIs from
your annotated Java code.
Another thing that the Google
Cloud Endpoints does for you
is, they take the complexity
out of multi-client development.
So I understand that while
you might be targeting Android
as a primary distribution
source, there's also iOS,
and there's JavaScript.
And so you can automatically
generate strongly
tied client libraries
for those platforms.
And then, finally, Endpoints
also take the risk out of API
development in the sense
that there is out-of-the-box,
built-in denial of
service protection.
There is support for all of 2.0.
And there's also support
for things like client
key management and so on.
So anyway, when you
combine these two things,
you get something
that's even better.
And so, in my mind, Android
Studio plus Cloud Endpoints
is the easiest way
for mobile developers
to get to Google Cloud platform.
And we have a whole
bunch of functionality
in Android Studio which
help you do just that.
So you can create
App Engine backends.
You can generate strongly
tied client libraries.
There are also a bunch of
quick fixes, and as you
type validations for when you're
developing the actual API.
And we're going to
show you all of this
during the demo in the
next 15 minutes or so.
And one thing I would just
like to mention as well
is that it's all using
Gradle as a build system,
so it's very well tied
together and unified
build across the command
line, across IDEA
for both the backend
and the front end.
So let's jump into the demo.
And we were thinking you've
seen a lot of cool demos today.
We were thinking,
what is something
cool that we could
show to you guys?
And first, we wanted to
show our own application,
just write something
from scratch.
But then we thought,
is that necessary?
And we found this.
We found the Todo.txt app,
which is a simple to-do task
management app.
It's on Play Store.
It's loved by Play Store users.
And it's using a different
cloud provider for the backend.
So let me just show you
the app, if we can just
cut to the mobile device.
This is the Todo.txt app.
As you can see, it
does all of the things
that you would expect
from a to-do app.
You can add a task.
You can mark a task as done.
Nothing groundbreaking,
but it's a nice little app.
Now, if we could cut back to
the slides for one more second.
Best of all, the
app is open source.
So we thought,
let's take the app.
Let's remove the different
cloud provider backend,
and let's add our own
cloud backend to it.
So let's cut back to the device.
This is exactly what we've done.
So, again, this
is a Todo.txt app.
But now instead of using a
different cloud provider,
it's using Google
Cloud Platform.
And so, again, as you would
expect, I can add a task.
Sorry, I'm going to try to add
a task during the demo, which--
Hero demo.
Sure, why not?
Good enough.
Yeah, so it works as expected.
And let's cut back
to the slide, please.
And in fact, it was
so simple and so easy
to do this transition from
taking an existing app
and adding a Google Cloud
Platform backend to it
that we're going to
show you right now,
live-- again, submitting
to demo gods--
how to do all of
this kid of stuff.
So we're going to start with
an app which is completely
stripped out of any kind
of backend, just the UI.
And then Rajeev is going
to do all the magic.
And he's going to
add a backend to it.
So over to you.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Cool.
Thanks, Manfred.
All right, so,
yeah, no pressure.
Let's write a backend.
All right, so here's
just the architecture
of what we're doing because
there's a lot of steps here.
On the left side, you
see the Todo.txt app,
which Manfred showed, and as we
dropped out the existing cloud
provider.
On the right-hand side,
you see the App Engine
backend that we
want to build here.
It's going to use a Cloud
Datastore to store and retrieve
tasks.
And what we're going to do
is then expose this backend,
using Cloud Endpoints.
And once you've exposed the
backend using Cloud Endpoints,
we can generate strongly
tied client libraries
and then use them over
in the Todo.txt app.
And then we can communicate
with the backend
to store and retrieve tasks.
So, OK, cool.
All right, let's
get started here.
All right, so we're starting
with the Todo.txt app.
So what does that look like?
All right, let me just go
to Android Studio here.
Then you guys can see it.
OK, so what I have on
the left-hand side--
you don't have to read
all the lines here--
but it's a Todo.txt
project here.
And there's a bunch of
modules-- Todo.txt Touch.
There's an action bar
widget and whatnot.
And what I was showing here
is the main build.gradle
file actually for the
Todo.txt Touch module.
So I'm not going to go
through everything here.
But as Manfred was
saying, this is
using the Gradle build system.
And this is written in Groovy.
So this is what the syntax
is that you're seeing.
And right here I've actually
got-- one thing I'll point out
is, if you look at the
compilation dependencies,
there's a bunch of jars
here, but then there's
a couple of project
dependencies, which
are actually just pointing
to the other modules there.
So this is kind of a key point
about using Android Studio.
All of your Android
applications use the Gradle
build system and give you
a much more rational way
to build your app and
do command line builds.
So cool.
OK, great.
Let's go back here just
to see where we're at now.
And all right, so
what I want to do now
is I want to generate an
App Engine backend that
has a Cloud Endpoints service.
Let's go and do that.
So I'm going to go
up here to Tools,
going to go to
Google Cloud Tools.
I'm going to say New
App Engine Module.
The template I'm going to use
is the App Engine Java Endpoints
Module.
Let's call this
Todo.txt Backend.
And the package name could be
Com Google Todo.txt Backend.
All right, that looks good.
So I'm going to generate.
All right, so couple
things going on here.
One, we basically have
a series of templates.
And you're seeing that over
here, from the template code,
we basically generated
all this code here.
And I'm going to go
through that in a second.
What's also going
on is you're seeing
that is says Gradle
sync in progress.
Because this is using
the Gradle build system,
any time you add a
module to your project,
it has to be built and absorbed
into the actual IDE via Gradle.
So that's why a synchronize
was going on here.
So if we're looking at
the Build Gradle file
here for the Android application
or the App Engine application,
you can see that this is
using the App Engine plug-in.
This is a Gradle
plug-in for App Engine.
The dependencies are
on the App Engine SDK.
You've got some compile
time dependencies here.
That's the Main Gradle file.
So let's hop into the code that
was actually generated, right?
MyBean is-- well,
it's, I guess, MyBean.
It's a pretty simple
class with a single field.
It's just got a string
field, as simple
as you can get
for a data object.
Again, this is part of the
template that we generate.
And we've got My Endpoint here.
OK, so My Endpoint's a little
more interesting because what
this is is it's a
Java class, but we're
exposing it as a Cloud Endpoint.
How are we doing that?
We're using the
Add API annotation,
which you see up here.
And I'm specifying
a name of myAPI,
which allows us to be
exposed as a Cloud Endpoint
with the API name myAPI.
But that's not much fun.
You need a method, right?
I mean, you have
to call something.
You attempt an RPC call.
So there's the sayHi method
that's also been defined here.
And we've expose this with
the API method annotation.
And we've given the name
here sayHi, as well.
And this is a really
simple method.
It takes a parameter,
creates MyBean or returns it.
So let's look at what
this looks like actually.
Let's see what
this actually does.
So I'm going to run this.
I'm going to run this, hit Play.
OK, so whenever we run an App
Engine app in Android studio,
because it's using Gradle, it
does a Gradle build beforehand.
And then what it does is it
kicks off the local development
app server.
You saw this in a
previous demo, actually.
And it's starting.
It just kicked me over there.
So it just started.
But basically, this
allows us to test locally
before deploying to production.
So let's take a look at what
our simple app looks like here.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
basically open up API Explorer.
It's an app that's basically
pointing to my local hosts
here to slurp in the
API meta-information
to provide me a view
over the rest API.
So you see that an API called
myAPI has been defined.
There's the sayHi method.
And it takes a parameter.
It's a name.
So I'm just going
to put in Manfred.
It's not my name.
It's his name But hit
Execute, and there we go.
So what actually
happened here, you
see that the Java class I
created with the annotations
has mapped pretty
well into a rest API.
If you look at the post-- just
zoom in here a little bit--
you've got myAPI up in
the name, version 1.
That's the method.
That's the data.
The response is, Hi, Manfred.
So that's basically
the API Explorer.
That's just showing
you how we're
exposing a Cloud
import really simply.
So, OK, let's go back
over to Studio here.
All right, let's stop
the Dev App server.
And OK, let's checkpoint
where we are here, all right?
So what we want to do is--
we've got the backend.
We've got a Cloud Endpoint.
That's great, but
that's not really
helpful for what we're
trying to do here.
We're trying to store tasks in
a data store and get them back.
So let's work on
that part of the app.
So I'll go back to Studio.
And what I'm going to do is--
so I'll start with this sample.
It's good.
I can get somewhere with this.
It's called MyBean.
I don't like that name.
So I'm going to actually
rename this to TaskBean.
All right, that's better.
Well, let me add
an ID field here.
I'm going to generate a
getter and setter for this.
I'll reformat the file
because that's a bit ugly.
All right, cool.
So now the bean with
an ID field, all right?
Now, OK, MyEndpoint-- so
this is where we actually
want to put in the logic for
what we're trying to do here.
So I'm going to rename this
to TaskApi instead of MyApi.
I'm going to drop
out the sayHi method
because we don't
need that anymore.
And I'm going to drop
in some code here.
And this is going to be code
to talk to the data store.
And it's going to expose three
methods-- clearTasks, getTask,
and storeTask.
GetTask will retrieve
tasks from the data store.
storeTask will store a
task in the data store.
And clearTasks will delete all
of them from the data store.
But I'm going to
drop in this code.
And them I'm going to talk
through what I did here.
All right, so I've just
dropped in a bunch of code.
And I'm just going to
resolve these imports here.
I'm going to use the
data store entity.
Let's see.
I want to use the App
Engine fetch options, want
to use Java to list.
Cool, I think I got them all.
OK, great.
Oh, there are actually a
couple of other errors here.
This one is actually
complaining because TaskApi,
it starts with a
capital letter here.
But when you're using
these rest APIs,
you're supposed to start
with lower case letters.
So I can just fix that.
That's a validation
that we wrote.
And I look here at
the getTask method,
and also I've got
a dot in the name.
It doesn't like that either.
So I'm just going
to fix that up.
And just to let you know, when
you're writing these Endpoint
classes, there's
a lot of helpers
for all these conventions.
If you go under
Inspections here,
you can see under
Google Cloud Endpoints--
you don't have to
read them all-- but
there's a variety of things
that'll help you with as you
type validation, as you
write Cloud Endpoint classes.
OK great.
So what did I actually do here?
So I've created three methods.
There's storeTask--
as I mentioned
to you-- getTasks,
and clearTasks.
So to go through
these really quickly,
I'm using the Data
Store Service here.
And what I'm doing
in storeTasks,
I'm basically creating
a new transaction.
And then for a TaskBean
that's coming in
from basically a client, I'm
creating an entity for that,
and I'm putting it
into data store,
and I'm committing
that transaction.
getTasks runs a query
over the data store
for all entities
of type TaskBean,
creates TaskBean
objects from them,
and returns them to the caller.
clearTasks is similar, except
it creates a transaction,
does that same
query, and then it
blows away all the tasks
that are in the data store
and commits a transaction.
So, OK, cool.
So looks like we
have our backend.
So what we need to
do now, I think,
is actually-- let's
just see where
we are so I can keep
track of where we are.
OK, cool.
Yeah, what I want
to do now is I want
to generate client
libraries, right?
I've got my backend.
I've exposed it through
Cloud Endpoints.
But someone's got
to use it, right?
And the thing that we want
to use it is an Android app.
So we need to generate
strongly tied client libraries
so that we can use
this on the other side.
So let me go ahead
and do that, actually.
So I'm going to go to
Tools, Google Cloud Tools.
And I'm going to pick
Install Client Libraries.
OK, so this is doing a
couple of things, right?
What it's doing is it's doing
a build of the App Engine app
because we've changed
a bunch of the code.
And it's going to then basically
get all the meta-information
from the annotations,
kick that up
to a cloud service,
which is going
to take that meta-information
and say, oh, hi, you need Java.
Here, I'm going to give
you a bunch of Java source
that you can use as a
way to call the Cloud
Endpoints from a
client application.
We grab that source.
We compile it.
And we install into your
local Maven repository.
So now you can access it on the
other side in the Android app.
So let's go ahead and
actually go and use
those client libraries
on the other side.
So now I'm going to go to the
Todo.txt Touch application
here.
And I'm going to drop in
the dependencies here.
So I've added a reference to the
libraries that were generated.
And this referencing
the local Maven repo.
And because I changed
the build Gradle file,
I've got to do a sync.
So let's do that.
And while that's going on, let's
just see where we're at here.
All right, so basically, we're
getting in the last stage
here, right?
We basically have our backend.
We've got our
client application.
We're generating the
client libraries.
Now what we need to do is
override the parts where
we actually call the cloud
provider, the existing cloud
provider from Todo.text
app and use ours instead,
the backend we created.
So let's go and do that.
All right, cool.
OK, so the magic
of this actually
all happens in a class called
TaskBagImpl-- not a great name,
I know.
It's a TaskBagImpl.
But anyway, there's
basically two methods here,
or four methods,
actually-- pushToRemote and
pullFromRemote.
And these methods, actually,
are doing what they're saying.
They're pushing the task to
the remote cloud provider
and pulling from the
remote cloud provider.
And you can see, in this
implementation here,
it's using the
remoteClientManager,
which is through the
existing cloud provider.
So let's extend this class
and override these methods.
I'm going to create a new
class here-- TaskBagImpl.
I'm going to extend TaskBagImpl.
And I'm going to drop in code
that overrides these methods
and actually calls our backend
instead of the existing backend
here.
So let's do that.
All right, I'm just going
to walk through the code
quickly here.
So what we've got
here is, basically,
an Endpoints TaskBagImpl.
I'm creating a new version
or a new instance of TaskApi.
And that's really the
thing that calls over
to the-- it's the thing that
we use to actually invoke
remote methods on our backend.
You'll see, in the
construction, I've
overridden the root URL
to point to 10.0.2.2.
That's because, when I run this
in the emulator, the Android
emulator, I want to run against
the local dev app server, which
is mapped to 10.0.2.2.
In pushToRemote, really-- I'll
just go through this really
quickly.
But we're basically grabbing
the list of the tasks that
are stored in the
local Android store,
creating TaskBean
objects, and then calling
storeTasks for
each one of those.
When we call
execute, that's when
the HTTP call happens
to our backend.
In pullFromRemote,
we call getTasks
which is the name of the
method we defined on that side,
execute, and we call getItems.
And then for each
one of those, we
create a new task
object, which is
what the UI understands
for this app.
And we call reload.
And that shows them up in
the Android application.
So let's go ahead
and just run this.
Let's try this out, actually.
So what I'm going
do is I'm going
to run the backend locally.
And while that's
actually going on,
I did remember there's one
thing I do need to change here.
I need to use our new actual--
the Endpoints TaskBagImpl.
So I'm going to
change that here.
Whoops.
Cool.
So looks like the dev
app server's running.
That's great.
And now while that's running,
I want to run the client app.
So I'm going to run that.
That's going to cause a
Gradle build to happen here.
You can see that, basically,
in the build process,
it's actually going ahead
and doing both the debug
and release builds
of the application.
You get that by default.
And you can actually
define many other variants
of your application
very easily in Gradle.
So I'm going to choose
the running emulator here.
All right, let's kick
over to the emulator
and see if we're working here.
OK, cool.
All right, so we're
running the emulator here.
So let me add a task.
OK, cool.
Add another one.
OK, I'll mark this as complete.
And let's look at
the backend and make
sure we're actually storing data
and I'm not deceiving myself
here.
So I'm running the API explorer.
You notice the API definitions
are now mapping to TaskApi.
I'm going to call getTasks here.
And basically, you
see the data here.
You see Hi there, Hi
cloud platform people
with the X. It's been
marked as completed.
That's why there's
a line through it.
So it looks like we're
up and running there.
Cool.
So this is great.
This is good times.
But one thing we actually
need to do is, well, hey,
we need to get this
to production, right?
I mean, that was the whole
point of the exercise.
So let's go, and let's do that.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to do a little housekeeping
so we can deploy this.
OAuth 2.0-- I'm going to use
OAuth 2.0 authentication.
I want to make sure my app
ID is set properly here--
cloud-platform-live-14.
Great.
And what I'm going
to do is deploy
this from the command
line, because I mentioned
we're using Gradle so I should
be able to do that, right?
So gradlew todoTxtBackend,
call App Engine update, which
uses a cloud SDK under the hood.
And all right, cool.
So before doing this,
it does a build.
Looks like it's going up there.
It was an updated SDK,
so should grab that.
Anyway, cool.
So looks like it's deployed.
All right, cool.
Let's actually use the
production backend on the phone
there.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yeah,
yeah, let's do that, Rajeev.
So let's see if I'm more lucky
this time with my fancy tablet.
So if we could cut to
the device-- ay yay
yay, black screen.
Let's try one more time.
Unplug, plug back in.
That solve all the problems
most of the time-- unplug,
plug back in.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Oh, no, that's me.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: So we'll
try the phone one more time.
MALE SPEAKER: Try again.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: OK,
OK, if that doesn't work,
let's use the
tried-and-true method.
OK, still nothing.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Try one more--
MALE SPEAKER: Try to
go back and forth.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
Oh, one more?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
There we are.
All right, OK.
So, Rajeev, what do
you want me to add?
So first of all, let me delete
this Hero task and then--
RAJEEV DAYAL: Just,
I don't know, say--
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Wrap up.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah, wrap up.
I like Rajeev.
I don't know.
Any of those things are fine.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
All right, then.
OK so I've tried adding
the wrap up task.
RAJEEV DAYAL: All right.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: And now if
you go to Developer's Console--
RAJEEV DAYAL: Cool, can you
flip over to the demo computer?
All right, I'm going
to refresh this here.
There we go-- wrap up.
Cool.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: All right?
RAJEEV DAYAL: All right.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: This
is a good time for applause.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEEV DAYAL: Thank you.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: All
right, so thanks, man.
So seriously, I
know this might not
have been the most exciting
demo of your lives.
But this was no
smokes and mirrors.
In 15 minutes, we took
this stripped out app,
and we added in a
cloud backend to it.
So I thought it
was kind of cool.
And you've seen things like
local dev app server and API
Explorer and how code gets
translated from Java to rest
and all of those cool things.
So anyway, if we can
go back to the slides,
I know you guys are eager
to get to the fireside chat
with [INAUDIBLE] and Jeff Dean.
So I'll just quickly lamblast
through these slides.
I would just like to mention
that while some of these things
are really cool
what we have now,
more of the exciting things
are coming, including support
for GC and improve getting
started experience,
API analytics, third-party
client access, and all
of those kinds of things
that you can look forward to
in I/O in 2014.
So I hope to see you all there.
Thanks so much for coming.
Thanks for being
attentive after the lunch.
I understand that that
can be quite hard.
And any questions?
Yes?
Actually, do we have a mic?
If not, you can just
yell the question.
I'll repeat that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was actually just curious
about the [INAUDIBLE].
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yeah, so
that's a very good question.
Let me just repeat it.
The question was
mostly, cloud developers
are using other IDs
outside of Android Studio.
And Android Studio
is mostly Android.
And so what's the further,
long-term plan there?
So our goal is to meet
you where you are.
And so partially,
one reason for that
was having the
[INAUDIBLE] backend
and front end build,
currently Android Studio
supports just Java.
There might be some things on
the roadmap to extend that.
Unfortunately, that's all
I can give at this point.
Thank you.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Though one
reason we did-- we want to say,
the backends that we're
creating there, especially
in Android Studio, are
really attuned to be
used by Android apps, right?
So that's why it's
still in Android Studio.
It's like just add a
cloud backend very easily
for the purpose of
your Android app.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
OK, last question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
OK, the question
was, when will there
be support from Android
wearables and Google Glass?
RAJEEV DAYAL: I mean, yeah we
haven't thought about that.
But technically, I mean,
with Cloud Endpoints,
if it's a Java, you can generate
bindings in any language.
And you're using HTTP, right?
So we haven't thought
about it, but I
don't see any actual
technical reason
why that would be
a problem, to use
a cloud-based backend
and Cloud Endpoints
to expose it to a
device like that.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: All right?
Thanks so much, guys.
Thank you.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Thanks.